عمل مصطفى 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم بسرعه
ومن غير تفكير اغنيه صنعت اسمك
من هو نجم مصر الاول اليوم
محمد منير
[موسيقى]
خالص
اوكي طيب سرحت انك ما راح تعطي الحانك لاي
احد ثاني وحتخليها كلها لك اعطيني اسم
واحد ممكن تستثنيه من هذا القرار واحده
واحده يعني طبعا
همم لو الاساس اتبانه صح في بدايته
هتطلعوا اغنيه هايله لو الاساس تبان غلط
الاغنيه هتلاقي فيها مشاكل كثيره وكله
هيرمي الفشل على الثاني
كيف بترد على اللي بينتقدوكم وبيقولوا
وعمل مصطفى كلها واحده او نفس اللون
زي
العالم والله
زي دايره
يبقى هو لازم يراجع الدكتور نفسه عشان
يعرف ان ده مش شبه ده يعني
طيب اقرب اعمالك لقلبك
دلوقتي هاقدر اقول لك يا دايره لانها
بتلخص سنه 2012
انا اللي فهمت متاخر انا غلطان
غريبه الدنيا وعجيبه انا
باتجدع الطيبه
كانه خلاص بقيت عيب تكون انسان
يبقى نودعين
حاضر طيب معروف عنك كثره الخلافات ولكن
رجعت قلت انك فتحت صفحه جديده وخلاص طيب
لكن برضو استمريت في التصريحات اللي بتزعل
الناس منك يعني طلعت في برنامج ورجع حتى
كذا مطرب كتبه بوستات ورجعوا عليكم ولحن
كتبوا سترد عليك وحتى انت حطيت بوست قلت
انه انت بس تتفرج على ردود افعالهم يعني
استمريت شويه صراحه
ما فيش مشاكل اللي حصل اللي بتقوليه ده
الاحداث دي حصلت قبل ما انزل اليه دايره
مش بعدين بعد ما نزلت اول اغنيه ليا اللي
هي من ثلاث شهور اغنيه همم انا جبت سيره
احد خالص وما حدش قرب مني يعني
وما نزلوش اغاني من ساعتها والله من اول
ما انا نزلت ما حدش نزل اغاني حبيبي قاعد
طب اعمل ايه طب هتفضح طب ما راح اعمل حاجه
خالص تمام
الناس كلها عايشه في عالم واحد على فكره
صغير يعني السوشيال ميديا خلاص انستغرام
لا خوف من الموسيقى
طيب قلت انه في مطربين بيشتروا مشاهدات
على يوتيوب من تقصد
اقول لك الناس تعرف ازاي عشان ارد على
السؤال ده ونعرفه بصوا يا جماعه لما تنزل
اغنيه على اليوتيوب وتلاقوا مثلا 50 مليون
بصوا على الكومنتات وبصوا لايكات اللايكات
ممكن تشتري لا يكون الكومنتات مش هتشتغل
فممكن تلاقي مثلا اغنيه سيبوه هتلاقي مثلا
عليها دلوقتي 6 مليون مشاهده 6 مليون
مشاهده هتلاقي مثلا 5000 6000 كومنت بس ما
ينفعش الاقي 47 مليون مشاهده والاقي عليها
نفس ال 5,000 كمان
كل الشعب دلوقت العربي يعرف ازاي المضروب
من الاصلي طيب بتحب تسمي احد تحديدا كمان
يروحوا ويلاحظوا صفحته اكثر
ثابت اليوتيوب
لا احنا اليوتيوب ده مش هانزل مثلا
لا فيه
يعني بالنسبه للتناسب مع الرجال اقل
عايزه تبتدي ان انت هي تذاكر وكده انا
مستعد
المجال او كده او انه
الرجال افضل من الستات الستات متفوقه على
الرجال في حاجات كثيره جدا
اوكي برافو عليك خلص اوكي طيب خلاص الناس
كلها انت صح
ههه
طيب اسمع الناس بتقول انك غيران من نجاح
مطربين مهرجانات علشان هم صاروا نجوم
اليوم
همم انا دي اولا انا عايز اولا دي
تتعمليها تمثال
والله يعني مراتي دي لازم يتعملها تمثال
كبير يعني تمثال في اماكن كثيره لان ما
فيش حد هيستحمل ال- ال- ال- المود المتغير
ده غير انسانه عظيمه ربه اولادي ودخلتهم
جامعات انا عندي بنت بتدرس في لندن وعندي
ابني الثاني بيدرس وعندي ابنه صغير وبنتي
بتدرس زي ما قلت لك في الارض همم هي عظيمه
انسان عظيمه وهي المسؤوله عن الاولاد في
تربيتهم وانسانه همم عظيمه
الله يخليكم لبعض متى شعرك بالفشل
الحمد لله عمري ما حسيت به لان انا راجل
ببقى خايف شويه قبل ما انزل اي حاجه
وبابقى وسواس جدا فاكيد اما بنزل حاجه
باكون
يعني ربنا موفقني فيها لاني ببقى
متردد قبل ما انزل بكثير يعني بختار
اختيارات دقيقه يعني انا ممكن يعني دائما
كان فيه يعني
احترم نفسك كثيره
الفنانه الفنانه اللي بحب احضر لهم حفله
منير بحب احضر حفلاته لانه مختلف
اعوذ بالله من كلمه انا واعوذ بالله من
الغرور
يرتقب نفسه البشريه ويحس ان هو ان هو يقيم
انت مغرور
30 3 خليها 50
الكلام ببلاش بس لما الناس هتشوفني في
الشارع هتعرف ان انا مش مغرور
20 يعني انا كنت بعمل لمستك ساعتها
لحد ثاني خلاص كنت هكمل
دي نصيحه اللي كنت مفروض اديها لنفسك
تغني لي مقطع منه
وانت اللي بحلم اعيش معاك
والليله هي البندق يعني انا عايز بس
المطربين يغنوها انا عايز المطربين يغنوها
يسمعوني صوتهم فيها ده واحد غير بارتاح
معاك
اه يا رب يا حبيبي لما نرجع للسؤال من
واحد لاخره جدا
قلقان لازم نرجع له طيب كل الاغاني اللي
اصدرها عمرو مصطفى في 20 22 سيبوه الا انا
يا دائره وغيرهم كل اغاني عنه وبيوجه فيها
رسائل لناس معينه صح او غلط
الحقيقه ان هو ال- ال- الشعره اللي بيكون
دائما اصحابي او اصدقائي او في الفتره
اللي انا بلحن فيها بيكونوا عايشين حاله
معينه يعني هي اغنيه يا دائره دي دي حالتي
من سنتين مش دلوقت سنتين بس انا نزلتها
دلوقتي لان انا وعدت الناس ان انا هانزل
كل الاغاني القديمه اللي عندي على
الموبايل ودي اعدادهم 1780 جنيه
1,780 اغنيه نزلت منهم اثنين سيبوه
همم طيب لحن الكل قال لك عليه لا واصريت
انك تنزله ونازل اكسر الدنيا
[موسيقى]
يعني الحمد لله بص هقول لك شويه حاجه
طالما انا بلحن كثير قوي قوي ده لحم في
اليوم مثلا كثير
20 اغنيه انا ما بتعجبنيش وجمله واحده
صغيره قد كده تعجبني واقعد بس ست شهور ما
تعجبنيش غير الجمله دي هي دي اللي بتنزل
للناس انا عندي اغاني كثيره جدا فمش دائما
همم باحس الاحساس ده لا بس في لحن ممكن
تكون انت عج- عجبك بس في ناس حواليك قالوا
لك لا مش حلوه بس بعدين نجح
همم
يمكن بطلع كل حاجه من قلبي قوي فببقى
حاسسها قوي محستتش الاحساس
انا ما باخذش رايك حد انا ببص في وشه اوكي
طيب اختار اغنيه واهديها لشخص معين
في حياتي
انا كل حاجه تغيرت
فياوى يعني دي مش شخص دي دي الروح
السنه انا عندي الخلاف حرفانه
شكرا